the president Trump is back in his
hometown of New York City this week for
the annual United Nations General
Assembly where he's meeting with fellow
heads of government including Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
French president manuel McCrone with his
America first slogan mr. Trump is an
intense critic of the UN for what he
believes is waste and mismanagement in
his first visit to the body as president
mr. Trump called for major reforms we
seek a United Nations that regains the
trust of the people around the world in
order to achieve this the United Nations
must hold every level of management
accountable protect whistleblowers and
focus on results rather than on process
we encourage all Member States to look
at ways to take bold stance at the
United Nations with an eye toward
changing business as usual and not being
beholden to ways of the past which were
not working alright great so previous
presidents may have said it but I think
that the United Nations thinks that this
one really means it yeah yes first of
all we have to talk about him calling
Kim Jong un rocket and I think he should
continue this he should refer to
Netanyahu as Benny in the Jets and
macron tiny dancer Donald Trump is
closest to American attitudes about the
UN that you will ever find you realize
to say yes we've all we've all figured
this out we all especially people who
live around this horrible place we it's
basically Epcot Center without the
amazing food court and like finally we
have a president that says says we're
gonna reform it and for the longest time
the UN has always pointed fingers at us
passing judgment on us while they double
park their limos they don't pay their
parking tickets they harass our call
girls they close down department stores
so they can buy their mistress a stuffed
boar when they tell us and I made that
up but I'm what I'm saying is that they
come here and they take advantage of
this country they have a free ride here
and it's nice that a president is saying
the word reform because reform means
we're now we we're now looking at you
mm-hmm we're looking at you you've got
to change your ways enough about us on
us I have to take issue with something
god Phil just said I've been to the UN
and their food court is fantastic
you get everything from all around the
wagon it's terrific I can't believe I'm
saying that of course for clarifying it
really thank you after some of the other
commentary I can't believe I'm saying
this I miss Gaddafi remember when
Qaddafi would come into right UN General
Assembly he would pitch a tent in
Central Park yeah we didn't let him do
that did we absolutely amazing
I know yeah cause of it I think the UN
is only as strong as the US makes it and
president Trump puts the bully and bully
pulpit he's gonna come in and say just
like you did with NATO pony up pay your
fair share
carry on burden because he realizes the
United States not gonna be able to pay
for this and do all this stuff forever
just like he did with NATO
now the Security Council has been more
useful to the president than the House
and the Senate to a certain extent he
hasn't got a lot legislatively done he's
got two unanimous UN Security Council
resolutions through sanctioning the
North Korean so I think Trump does well
in the world stage because you used to
deal with CEOs and executives not
legislatures where it's really hard to
cobble together big coalition's and you
see him as a man of action dealing with
other world leaders very effectively and
I think the speech tomorrow's gonna be
even tomorrow before today excuse me I'm
excited about the speech I want to talk
about it in a second but even before
today you had people in the region of
Asia China Japan South Korea all sort of
changing his defense postures because
the time is now to deal with North Korea
and the president Trump made it clear
over the weekend and then as he's
talking to everybody today I'm sure
behind the scenes this is priority
number one absolutely and this is really
a great time it's you know fortuitous in
terms of the timing to try to build
these coalition's and strengthen the
resolve to do something with North Korea
now because it's not gonna get any
better if we just delay of game right so
they've got to do something I think
people are ready for it and I think they
feel that President Trump is the man to
get you know the job done so I like kind
of like the coalescing of interest and
resolve towards that common goal and I
think
today what we heard with the president
you want to talk about in a second but
really shows like Jesse said he's very
comfortable in the world stage in
dealing with world leaders who he sort
of interacts with like CEOs of major
companies it fits his business model and
his mindset versus like disparate people
and you know the legislature etc that he
can't quite get a grasp on he likes when
he's one-on-one with she or he likes
when he's you know talking to that of
South Korea about Rocketman you know he
likes those type of one-on-one
conversations and he really gets to have
the main world stage one because
President Putin and president G so
Russia and China those leaders did not
attend this week so he basically can run
the table why don't you run the table
but I think this is his show and I mean
everybody's looking forward to his
appearance tomorrow before the General
Assembly this is Trump on the world
stage in a way that I think we have not
seen before we've seen him overseas he
dealt with NATO in terms of another
multilateral group and said basically
you should pay up well of course
everybody then said well exactly GDP is
a percentage of GDP actually United
States and other countries are paying up
but he wants me to pay more and he has
seen some of the countries then pony up
more money so it did have some effect
and I think that's similarly tomorrow
you know while people have trouble with
Trump with Rocketman or this weekend the
business about you know the retweeting
the image of a golf ball hitting Hillary
Clinton in the back and her stumbling
people think this is trivial but
tomorrow it's hard to look at him as
something less than a world leader
standing in front of the UN and speaking
about something that the entire world is
concerned about which is North Korea I
mean that is what is front and center
tomorrow there are other issues and
we're going to get to some of them later
in the program dealing with Iran or the
Paris climate deal but tomorrow he's got
an audience that wants to hear from him
that wants to support him wants to see
leadership in terms of dealing with Kim
jong-un I also want to see more of that
golf ball video I thought it was funny
he I'm okay saying it's funny roll it
baby laugh I don't think it was funny as
I said that it that the world leader the
guy that you want to see he didn't put
it together he just retweeted it on
Twitter you can retweet stuff but not
endorse it
tweeting is not an endorsement online if
it's funny it retweeted yeah we've all
done it yeah if you're president United
States that's what makes Trump Trump
doesn't care you got to look at you got
to look at Twitter the way he looks at
it he just looks at it as something fun
and interesting and it drives people
nuts and makes them crazy they get all
upset about it and don't get it if you
don't get upset then it's nothing
and it wasn't presidential on it was
modern day president it wasn't modern
day president that's trying to expand a
base I think he was playing to the worst
of his oh yeah it was it was it was
really was dr. ball never actually
punched her that's what that's the image
that he wanted to send to the world
I just wanna present that people know
that it's not real
and also the play in Central Park about
they killed the president for seven days
straight those are the same of course
it's not the same do you think Kathy
Griffin holding a head that's the same
as that actually I think all of its bad
have I done I could see any great Asian
I could see little golf ball tapping her
on the back and married to hurt
stumbling is a little bit different it's
playful it's funny yeah he's just
responding to the book that's all
literally I'm Kimberly in addition I'm
more important topics the president met
with Israel Prime Minister Netanyahu
today and they're trying to talk about
you know be fairly Gentiles peace yes
okay so listen another great
relationship an alliance between these
two countries and we saw right away in
the beginning of the Trump presidency
that he had the favor of Netanyahu that
they were like-minded people working
very closely together with confidence
and I would say also trust in one
another he really believes that
President Trump is a friend to Israel
and
real has reiterated back that they are a
friend to the United States so I think
that's like one relationship that's
going quite well and they seem to be on
the same page and so that's that's
something been acting in concert towards
a common in